[Music]
it is known as the rainbow nation for
its cultural linguistic and religious
diversity its constitution alone
acknowledges 11 different languages yes
this is South Africa a country situated
in the extreme south of Africa this is
not a small country its surface area is
larger than Germany France Italy Belgium
and the Netherlands combined it is by
far the most developed economy of all
the countries situated south of the
Sahara Desert in the year 2000 again it
was the first African country to hold a
Soccer World Championship this was the
Summer of Shakira's like a waka if
anyone cares to remember that
various important months in South
Africa's history with April 1994 between
the 26 and 29 of their months South
Africa celebrated the first free
universal and democratic elections they
were also the longest because the
elections lasted for four long days
during that time South Africans last
thousand massively to vote having to
wait in queues at kilometres long live
was justified for these elections meant
the end of 300 years of colonialism and
white supremacy the elections marked the
end of apartheid apart by apartheid was
a system based on racial segregation
which remained in effect for 50 years it
mainly consisted of separating the white
population from the black population
this applied in any situation living
studying even the spending of leisure
time obviously as you might imagine all
of the rest areas and services were
built for and used by the white
population a good example of this with
the ambulances even though the black
population were 80% of the population
they barely had any ambulances - you
however the ambulances for the white
population were numerous and refused to
carry any black passengers because they
couldn't according to the law
[Music]
apartheid gave the white population all
the political power and also established
many limitations precisely in order to
consolidate that white power as an
example mixed-race relationships and
marriage were completely forbidden quite
simply it left the black population in
an inhumane situation
[Music]
it can be said that there were two
different South Africa's one black and
terribly poor and the other white and
very wealthy and of course those who
rebelled suffered terrible punishments
and repression on the 16th of June 1976
thousands of black students went on a
demonstration to demand social and
educated improvement hundreds of them
were massacred
I've got injured in my back I have a sky
in my back I was running about the train
speed sounded here fighting away from
there from the police
Mandela dreams but all that changed in
thanks to Nelson Mandela also known as
Madiba he was considered the father of
the country
Mandela led the political fight against
apartheid and racism that he had to pay
for it in 1961 he was sentenced to life
imprisonment for the trail Mandela spent
27 years in jail until 1992 nevertheless
two years after his release in 1994
during the country's first free
elections he was elected as the
president of South Africa the first
black president in the country's history
after this happens many were surprised
to see Mandela aiming for reconciliation
rather than revenge and dela dreamt of a
free United and prosperous South Africa
he made it clear in his inaugural speech
we have first in the effort to implant
hope in the press on the middle of our
people we enter into a covenant that was
until to society in which all South
Africans both black and white will be
able to atone without any skill in Jihad
a third of the action Ahmir the
providers imagine a rainbow nation at
peace with the Sun and the world
Mandela kept his work he worked towards
the United South Africa and when the
time came he left power following the
limits of the Constitution this all
turned him into a legend for the country
what is robbed a survey the past is the
past we look to the future now
well let's now focus on present-day
South Africa it is the only country in
the world to have three capital cities
Cape Town the capital city for
legislative power Pretoria for executive
power and in bloom Fontaine see
judicial capital city and on top of all
that neither is the most populated or
the one where most businesses
concentrate to that we have to move to a
fourth city Johannesburg it's even not
uncommon for different textbooks to stay
two different cities and the capital of
South Africa now after the fall of
apartheid South Africa experienced quite
an economic boost since 1994 the economy
considering purchasing power has tripled
[Music]
poverty has been strongly reduced and
hundreds of thousands of black families
make it into the middle class every
single year and even though violence is
still high it does need to be said that
South Africa is quite a violent country
it has also been reduced further in
general the access to drinkable water
electricity and health care has also
improved quite a lot to illustrate the
situation South Africa is the biggest
tourist center and financial power in
the south of the continent its stock
market is the most important in Africa
and it is also an important place for
the automotive industry companies such
as BMW and General Motors have factories
here so it all sounds pretty good right
well thanks today are actually not
looking that rosy crazies and defamation
despite its numerous achievements the
economy hasn't changed since 2009 the
economy isn't growing unemployment rates
are one of the highest in the world and
in general very few people are working
the country has a population of about 55
million people 15 million of which are
without work and many of the jobs that
the people do have are informal and this
is not the only problem investment by
companies has also kept the decreasing
in the last nine years its currency the
rands has also greatly depreciated and
public debt is about to be declared as
junk bonds this is a pretty major
economic disaster in fact in the last
year's people with money have begun
leaving the country so the big question
is what happens in South Africa what led
to this crisis
yes customer this is Jacob Zuma he's
been in office since 2009 and his years
in office have been well they've been a
giant mess the man is facing a 783
corruption cases and he has been
described at being a professional at
taking things that are not his South
Africa's main opposition party is
accusing President Jacob Zuma of
flagrant abuse of public money they've a
multi-million euro upgrade to his home
additions to Zoomers home include a
swimming pool cattle enclosure and an
amphitheater but this is not the only
issue
mr. Zuma's political decisions don't
encourage foreign investment so the
president's labour regulations are an
obstacle when it comes to job creation
and the regulations are getting more and
more rigid his last idea it was a huge
raise in the minimum wage something that
doesn't make a bunch of sense in the
country where there are so few working
people in fact many financial analysts
have criticised the measure by saying
it's nonsensical to establish a minimum
wage which amounts to twice as much as
half of workers are making now to be
honest we all do want our salaries to
raise but I think it's a better idea to
create some wealth first if job creation
was already an issue before imagine
what's going to happen with higher
salaries and the South Africa it has
other problems too an important one is
it's problematic education system
[Applause]
[Music]
an awful education system the education
system in South Africa is pretty awful
picture this one in every three students
who is attended school for six years has
difficulty when it comes to something as
essential as reading and only one in
every 100 black students gets an
engineering diploma so we can probably
now understand why national companies
complain about the difficulty of finding
skilled labor and this has got nothing
to do with money South Africa is one of
the countries with the highest
investment in education in the world
so the big question is what is happening
well according to some people the ones
who are to blame are the Democratic
teachers union they control the state
education system and it has become
something of a mafia the union is an
ally of President Zuma zoomer besides
putting an end to education supervision
has also pulls many strings to get more
teachers into the system this has caused
the education level of teachers
themselves to become very low now a few
years ago maths teachers in the country
were given a test these features where
teaching math to 11 and 12 year olds
what was the result well eight out of
these teachers got lower results than
were expected of their student and to be
honest here maths is not exactly one of
President Zoomers strong suit this is
President Zuma attempting to say 769
thousand eight hundred and seventy seven
hundred and sixty nine eight hundred ten
seven hundred this intra-party eight
hundred ten twenty now obviously the
results for white students who go to
private schools are far better this
shows that maybe some of the apartheid
heritage is still very much in effect
we're still conflicts if these problems
weren't bad enough racial conflict in
South Africa has also been growing in
the last few years the economic freedom
fighters is a radical political party
that was founded in 2013 this party is
now the third largest force in the
country some of its members are
suggesting to almost invert apartheid
and plan to the white population it is
still a minority party but is an element
of subversion it is working quite well
so anyway it now looks as if Mandela's
dream is now in danger so this is what
we think here at visual politic what
what do you think do you think the South
Africa will continue to be few Nelson
Mandela's Dreams do you think it will
become the most prosperous nation in
Africa once again what do you think
hatred distrust and bad politics will
triumph do let us know in the comments
section below this video we'd love to
know what you think also if you did
enjoyed this video please do click that
thumbs up button below and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday there's a button below the
video as well as on the screen now so be
sure to click on that and as always I'll
see you in the next video
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
my temple once what is there left